foreign
for the Press preview then it's our
first look at what is on Monday's front
pages tonight we'll be having a look at
the papers with Jasmine Cameron chileshi
political correspondents at the
financial times and Madeleine Grant
assistant comment editor of the Daily
Telegraph evening to both of you uh
let's have a look at the front pages
that we've got so far then nurses give
sunac the double digits that's the front
of the Metro after the leader of the RCN
said her nurses should now get a
double-digit pay rise instead of
settling for five percent as originally
recommended and rejected
the guardian looks ahead to tomorrow's
speech by the Home Secretary in which
she's expected to call for far lower
immigration numbers and insists it's not
racist to want tighter border controls
the eye says the speech will increase
pressure on Wishy soon act to be tougher
on the migration issue
the express says there's growing outrage
at what's being seen as Labor's plan to
reopen brexit by giving millions of EU
citizens the vote in the UK
well the Daily Mail says some fear care
starmark will use the move to try to rig
future elections
Jasmine's paper the Ft reports that G7
and EU countries are to ban Russian gas
Imports on Pipeline routes where Moscow
has cut supplies if it tries to reopen
them to boost its economy
the mirror shows rugby player Rob Barrow
triumphantly crossing the line with help
in a charity marathon in Leeds after he
was diagnosed with motor neuron disease
in 2019 really moving those pictures the
sun has the latest news about the future
of itvs this morning presenter Philip
schofields and the Daily Star brings the
disappointing news that the summer many
were expecting to arrive in the next few
days actually won't happen until next
month
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see on screen join the
program use your Mobile check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you're watching us and we are joined
tonight by Jasmine Karen gillesi of the
financial times and Madeleine grants of
the Daily Telegraph great to see you
both thanks for your time this evening
and let's get cracking Jasmine front
page of the Metro nurses give sunac the
double digit initially they were asking
for 19 weren't they then accepted five
percent and that one-off payment now Pat
Cullen uh is playing hard hard ball
isn't she with the government
so it's quite an interesting development
in that she is warned that actually
nurses could be willing to strike up
until Christmas unless the government
sits down and renegotiates a deal now we
know that the government had um there
was a vote by the NHS staff Council
earlier this month which saw the vast
majority of Health unions um supports
the government still which included the
one-off payment and a five percent pay
hike but we know that the r and RCN was
one of a handful of Health unions that
actually pushed back against the
government still and voice that they
weren't happy with it and so now we're
in a situation where the nursing Union
is is warning that actually its members
are going to ballot
um and you know there's there's the the
threat of potentially more strikes and
this obviously comes at the back of
um you know quite uh intense strike a
few weeks ago which saw nurses on
intensive care units and cancer units um
walking out for the first time and so it
really feels as though this is you know
quite a significant development and
where a nursing Union is saying yes
there is a deal on the table yes it's
been accepted by other health unions but
actually this isn't going to work for us
and all of this will likely put further
pressure on the government because if we
step back now this the public sector
um dispute not just between the
government and health unions but also
some of the teaching unions and some of
the rail workers has actually been going
on for months now and actually there is
a general feeling that ultimately is the
government's responsibility to make sure
that public services are well funded and
well run and all of this does reflect
badly on the government and and you know
where she's seeing its administration at
the moment yeah Madeleine does it also
reflect quite badly on Pat Cullen
because she's misjudged this hasn't she
well it's slightly awkward for her
because it is a pretty sizable uh u-turn
on her previous position she had
previously told her members uh when they
were balloted she had written to them
telling them to accept the five percent
pay rise and then when they had the vote
on it it they voted it down by a margin
of 54 to 46 which isn't exactly a kind
of slam dunk position and now she's
pivoted to I think putting on quite a
bullish front and talking in quite
alarming terms about the possibility of
a strike or sporadic strikes until
Christmas
um but it is nevertheless a a quite a
major pivot from her previous position
and suggests that beneath the bullish
front there was actually a fair bit of
disagreement within the profession about
the next course of action yeah and just
briefly Madeline what what about the
public I mean if strikes do go on until
the end of the year do you think do you
think nurses will begin to lose support
of the public
I think that that Jasmine's right that
the ultimately the blame will lie with
the government and that the public will
have a great deal of Sympathy for the
nurses um in general I think that there
is a huge amount of of Good Will and
support in general uh for nurses but I
do think that the longer it goes on and
the more discussion there is about the I
suppose the internal wrangling of the
RCN it may just be more difficult to
keep up that uh United front and the the
bullish talk of of of maintaining
strikes for months until or possibly
till the end of the year okay let's move
on to the front of the Guardian then uh
Jasmine there seems to be a cabinet
split doesn't this well Abraham we know
is going to make a speech tomorrow but
there is a split between those wanting
to ease visa rules and the likes of the
Home Secretary wanting to reduce net
migration which really is increasing at
quite a pace
yeah so we know that the home sector is
due to give a speech tomorrow where
she's going to argue that in some of the
sectors where we know that there are
high staff vacancies for example um
agriculture the hospitality sector that
actually businesses should be looking to
um UK Nationals to fill those gaps
rather than looking overseas and there
is this um this huge tension in cabinet
at the moment because you have
individuals like swalla Berman who would
argue that actually the conservative
government
um you know campaigned on this idea of
controlling borders and wants to reduce
the the numbers of um migrants coming
into the UK and then you have other
figures within the cabinet for example
the education sector and the chancellor
saying look well actually we've got a
lot of sectors that you know that need
filling that are vital to the economy
and actually it's no bad thing to be
looking overseas and trying to think how
we can con bolster the economy and and
to fill some of these gaps and so you
know I think this is this is a tension
that we will see played out especially
heading into the next election where
conservatives have to outline to their
voters you know what controlling
immigration actually means and you know
where the vacancies lie and how much
control the government can have over
over migration levels so I think this is
just you know this is not the last we
hear of this I suspect we'll be hearing
you know lots of discussions uh played
out on the newspapers over the next few
months ahead yeah front page of the I
Madeleine cynic Under Pressure to get
tougher on migrants
um I mean there has been quite a lot of
criticism hasn't there over the weekend
from his own party from the conservative
Democratic organization yesterday we've
got the national conservative conference
tomorrow
um uh there's very little let up
yes quite right and you know obviously
this is rather than being quite sort of
gung-ho and going out there and openly
criticizing government policy and for
the Home Secretary to be doing that
publicly is you know it's it's it's a
headache for for number 10 but equally
you know she is tapping into a pretty
rich theme of disenchantment amongst
um not just conservative Grassroots
members but also conservative voters
that the fact that despite in you know
in many cases having voted for brexit
and having repeatedly voted for
governments that were promising lower
migration the fact that regardless of
what the public does at The Ballot Box
the number just seems to keep increasing
um and you know the government's line
has been
um
for the most part that this is
inevitable given the abnormally high
levels of migration that have happened
because of accepting refugees from
Ukraine and from uh Hong Kong and and
other parts of other war-torn parts of
the world but I think that actually if
you dribble down to the numbers quite a
lot of it is economic migration and
particularly students coming and
potentially bringing their dependents
with them so really it's it's not I
don't think the government will be able
to dismiss this as a kind of simple
aberration as a result of British
Britain being uh generous in accepting
refugees and I don't think that line
will hold for long okay well it's a a
another migrant migration story on the
front of the Daily Express as well this
story was on the front of the mail on
Sunday uh today uh Jasmine all about
this scheme labor scheme to give EU
migrants who live permanently in the UK
and pay taxes at the chance to vote
yeah so this story's been playing out um
throughout the weekend as he as you say
this is um Labor's um potential package
of reforms if they get into government
looking at expanding um voting rights
for some EU Nationals as well as perhaps
16 and 17 year olds and you know the
party has been Keen to stress that
actually nothing has been firmed up
these are just discussions that are
ongoing but it's provoked um quite a
fierce backlash from some within the
conservative party who suggests that
this is labor um you know perhaps
they're trying to
um fiddle with the electorate perhaps
they're trying perhaps there's something
more underhand but I do think if you
actually look at what um you know I
think it was the shadow business
secretary was was on air this morning
that the labor party's argument is that
actually it's about expanding democracy
and that if you are um a resident in
illegal resident in the UK and you're
paying taxes and there's no reason why
you shouldn't be able to vote and we
also know in places like Scotland
um 16 year olds are also able to as well
and so the labor party's argument is
that this is just about making voting
slightly fairer but obviously there's a
lot of skepticism from the conservative
party and you know obviously we'll have
to see what this policy looks like in
practice and how far it actually extends
we know that in 2020 I think starma his
comments were quite wide reaching but
what's being brief seems to be or
perhaps a limited
um extension of voting rights to EU
Nationals so so we'll have to see the
you know a bit more detail in the coming
months yeah labor put out quite a vague
statement last night on this it
certainly doesn't seem to be firm policy
but critics are jumping on it aren't
they Madeleine just a very quick thought
from you before we go to the break
but quite right I mean I think that this
is a great example of how labor can
often be Their Own Worst Enemy you know
just as they are starting to look
sensible and electable they manage to
come up with an idea that would alienate
millions of people I mean it's not I do
think it's a it's a would be a
fundamental change letting EU citizens
in the UK vote even if there was no
reciprocal arrangement in their own
country you know I think however they
tried to spin this it will look like
gerrymandering to a lot of people and
also a fundamental change in the way
that we view citizenship and the rights
and obligations that come with that
versus
um uh people who've come to live and
work here but have not yet obtained
citizenship okay all right we must leave
it there and head to a break after that
the Metro reports on Turkish general
election where president erdogan is
fighting to remain in power after 20
years don't go away
[Music]
thank you
welcome back Jasmine and Madeline are
still here uh Jasmine front page of the
Ft um tell us about this uh embargo on
Russian gas
yeah so it's a highly um significant
move so the ft is reporting that
um at the G7 Summit which is used to
take Plan take place in Japan shortly
that leaders will agree to ban Russian
um gas imports from routes where Moscow
has cut some of the supplies now this is
actually a highly significant
development and I think it really
um is indicative of the fact that
actually you know more than a year after
the invasion of Ukraine actually Western
allies are still very much United
they're very much committed to
maintaining pressure on President Putin
and I think it speaks to a wider shift
that's happening in Europe at the moment
where countries are are re-examining
their their relationship with with
Russia in terms of energy usage and are
looking to to alternative energy sources
and looking at how do we Shore up energy
security and how do we make sure we're
not in a position where a country like
Russia can weaponize energy supplies so
I think it's a highly significant
development and actually you yeah it
speaks the fact that at this stage in
the conflict countries are figuring or
realizing actually this is potentially a
wall that could be going on for several
years and actually it's important for
countries to shore up their energy
supplies and to make sure that they
aren't put in a vulnerable position
themselves yeah Madeleine the paper
making the point that storage levels are
now pretty high
yeah that's right that actually when
faced with the crisis I mean initially
the Western response was in some cases
quite modeled with different countries
doing different things some countries
being far more sympathetic to Russia and
but pretty soon there was a fairly
united front was established there and
and now as Jasmine says we seem to be in
a position where
um Western Powers have actually taken
gone to Great Lengths to ensure that
they have Diversified their supplies and
that they will not be so Reliant in the
future so actually moscow's attempts to
exert that kind of um economic Warfare
um haven't been as successful as we
might have expected
and the other main story on the front of
the uh ft it's also inside the Metro as
well the election in turkey and and
Jasmine 88 turnouts is huge isn't it
shows the significance of this general
election
yeah and of course president erdogan has
you know this is a key moment for him
he's been in power for you know I think
it's around 20 years now and what's been
quite interesting is that the I think
it's the six opposition parties have
unified around a single candidate in
that they you know they didn't want the
vote to be split and so there's you know
this is clearly a big moment for the
country and it also comes amid a
backdrop of we've had those two
earthquakes and we also have
um you know rampant inflation throughout
the country and so there's a lot of
focus on Earth one's leadership there's
a lot of questioning of it and I think
it you know is a hugely symbolic
election in the fact that under
President erdogan the country has kind
of moved into a perhaps less Democratic
um more authoritarian regime and what
the opposition party what the opposition
parties are offering to the Turkish
public is actually you know a
potentially a different vision for the
country so it's a highly influential
action yeah we're just looking at
supporters as president erdogan Outsider
his HQ there in Anchor they've been
waiting those flags uh for hours uh
Madeleine at the moment he's uh just
below the 50 threshold so there's a high
likely that likelihood that we might be
here again in two weeks for a runoff
yeah exactly and we know that um
erdogan's party is essentially objecting
two results in hundreds of places
anywhere where it is way behind
um and you know that there are serious
questions I think about you know if the
result is is close or indeed will if
other one were to not to win would they
would they accept
um defeat I mean it's it's very it's
very hard to say I mean this is a very
authoritarian
um government in charge um the prisons
are full of his political opponents
um and of course in 2017 I think there
was a a constitutional referendum in
turkey that massively expanded his
powers and his remit so you know it's
it's highly significant I mean for
various reasons
um things have been going particularly
badly for everyone in turkey and the um
the rampant inflation there has almost
decimated the any kind of a middle class
that once existed in turkey and um turn
out amongst young voters seems to be
enormous who have
we're going to leave it there we'll
speak again in half an hour right now
we're gonna have a look at the weather